alors oui trac nous a dit tout à l'heure
que vous disiez toujours la vérité donc
on va voir on va faire l'interview
hollywood swiss ait entre basique in
sting pts 2 et marie antoinette lequel
vous détestez le plus payé 1,5 tous et
ça c'est le le le plus horrible ttc
incroyablement moderne voilà dix ans
connaître a quand même des très bonnes
choses de dos oui mais qu'est ce que
sofia coppola doit encore apprendre à
sofia coppola est une belle mais
réalisatrice elle avait cette vision la
critique n'a pas suivi mais le public
semble l'avoir suivie jusque au mans
mais le fait de comparer marie
antoinette des bases et alpha 2 un des
plus mauvais films jamais réalisés
au-delà du pire si vous voyez ce film
l'argent devrait aller vous voulez à
part ça ça m'avait plu
ah oui qu'est ce que vous n'aimez pas à
hollywood allez-vous d'être un club
fermé
oui moi je me suis dit ce serait plutôt
comme rome à l'époque ancienne
il fallait être spartacus en quelque
sorte pour déclencher une révolte
vous avez une les grosses médor des gros
studios qui sont identiques mais c'est
un mois ils s'intéressent davantage à
l'argent et ce n'est qu'une question
d'argent de grossesse est alors si les
gens disent qu'on est dur c'est eux qui
nous ont apprécié qui nous ont durci les
le fait que ce soit ailleurs c'est ça
qui nous a permis de les combattre parce
qu'avant avant lui personne ne pouvait
rivaliser avec des studios des petits
réalisateur de ce disciple à sochaux
écrasés maintenant ils ont plus de
pouvoir lâcher parce que nous avons été
dur quel est l'acteur hollywood qui
mérite plus 20 millions de dollars par
film
la plupart d'entre eux qu'est ce que les
français font mieux que les américains
au cinéma français ont un cinéma plus
intime du personnel laugnac et le
spectateur voit son intelligence
l'atc d'être les acteurs sont
intelligents le personnage du scénario
et c'est d'être à des gens et on n'est
pas condescendant par rapport aux coupes
hic c'est qu'on relève le niveau
alors qu'avez vous pour attirer un
maximum de public on nivelle par le bas
alors que m
en france la tendance à des temps dans
votre sens et les comédiens sont très
dure en général gérants et aux copies
l'école et dix français
weber ou des grands alors que pitau à
hollywood avant c'est long il ya ce film
a pu témoigner vous qu on va payer
je le dis ici au cul moi je les appelais
avis qu'est-ce qui vous a énervé
récemment chez tom cruise iphone fait
c'est sa religion orthodoxe et c'est
tout match est homme a été un petit peu
étroit d'esprit c'est quelqu'un de très
sympa que je connais très bien
on a vécu quand même il me faut dans
l'otan en une seule famille - mais ces
derniers temps alors oui je crois qu'il
a pris peur fermé mais il va se rouvrir
je pense dans les premiers à venir c'est
ce que je pense sinon vous voir de film
si ma production en face c'est un très
beau n'être l'oeil à gaspard car et vous
qu'est-ce que n'importe quelle actrice a
de plus que nicole kidman mais moi j'ai
fait sept films avec nicole kidman il
comprise le film pour lequel l aigle
nascar et d absolument gradins
extraordinaire sous tous ses aspects et
films comiques sérieux nicole kidman et
audacieuse
accepter en 15 millions $ d'un studio et
puis finalement le travail gratuitement
sur dr house que j'ai fait avec elle ou
encore une fois sur un petit projet elle
est très généreuse qu'elle filme avez
vous regretté de produire être prêt à
porter avec robert altman
mon problème c'est que j'ai jamais
rencontré marché de marbre ahlmann ami
avec sophia loren du rating et j'ai
oublié de faire mon job de producteurs
j'ai passé mon temps avec marcello toute
la journée jeux la compagnie de
matériaux soi il m'a emmené à déjeuner
il me racontait toutes les anecdotes sur
fellini des sikhs à tous les ses héros
de mon enfance pendant huit semaines
j'ai oublié mon travail alors robert le
maine m'a dit mais je te vois jamais tu
passes tout autant avec marcello alors
j'ai pas pu vraiment participer au film